[Music]
hi my name is Brennan I'm an engineer on
the brain team at Google and I work on
cloud GPUs so that's we're gonna talk
about today so to begin with I wanted to
start with a little bit of motivation
why ytp use what are we here this is a
chart that I'm actually really quite
fond of it was recently published by
open AI on their their AI blog and it
traces over the last six years a number
of seminal advancements that have
happened in the field of deep learning
you can see on the Left alex net which
is one of the ones that the models that
really kicked off the deep learning
revolution that we're experiencing today
as you go farther to the right you can
see more advanced vision models but you
also see whole new capabilities being
unlocked translation deep speech with
audio processing neural machine
translation dota 1 v1 uh you know
real-time game playing and one of my
favorites
alphago 0 and alpha 0 at the top right
and as deep learning has progressed you
know we've gotten more and more stuff
that were able to do with deep learning
which is really cool but if you notice
the y-axis of the plot we need not just
linearly increasing amount of compute
we've exponentially more compute
unfortunately just as we need
exponentially more compute to do deep
learning and unlock this world of
possibilities Wars law or in particular
running into the end of Dennard scaling
single single core clock performance not
improving very much single thread
performance IPC has basically hit a
brick wall even though we're still
increasing the number of transistors
that trend is even starting to slow down
more recently and so we're really in
between a rock and a hard place
and so we at Google we realized that
deep learning was so important and we
realized that it was so broadly
applicable that we started investing in
custom accelerators all the way back in
25 even before 2015 so in the top left
hand corner is our first-generation TPU
they're actually these actual devices
available in the
booth over there if you're here in
person a first-generation TPU is
designed just for inference only so
serving a model after it's been trained
this is very important as we're
deploying our first large-scale deep
learning models at Google
but over time we realize that training
was just incredibly hard to do and to do
it well and so we started investing in
our second-generation TPU which you see
in the middle here but we realized that
in order to train bigger more powerful
models we need to have these teepees all
linked together and focus on a single
task in a very tight tightly coupled
fashion and so these TPU devices are
really designed to be deployed in TPU
pods which you can see on our top
right-hand corner but deep learning is
advancing so rapidly and there's so much
possibilities for this field
we've been iterating extremely quickly
and at the bottom our third generation
TPU pod is over eight times faster and
is available just less than a year after
our second-generation TPU pod so we're
really excited about all that we can do
with GPUs and we're excited to bring
them to you as part of cloud GPUs so
that's our motivation for why we're here
this is what I'll be talking about today
and a first is a life of a TPU program
let's dig into what actually happens
underneath the hood when you're running
on a cloud TPU the second part is what
do you want to do how do you actually
program these TPU devices and the third
part we'll spend a few minutes talking
about one of the most common stumbling
blocks that people run into when they
first using GPUs which is how to keep
them fed fast enough they're just so
fast it really is an interesting
engineering challenge to feed data so
with no further ado let's let's dig
right in so if you want to run a program
on a cloud TPU well you've got to
provision your cloud TP your resources
and so let's talk a little bit about
that we show this picture of like one
cloud TPU device right this is our
second generation TPU device but really
you never see them bare like this in our
data center these are specialized
devices and they're not general-purpose
right they're optimized just for machine
learning so in practice we deploy them
often in what we call these pod
configurations so here you've got to
middle racks of teeth views you actually
have an 8 by 8
eight or 64 total cloud TPU devices
hooked together in this custom mesh
network and flanking these 64 TPU
devices are actually 64 general-purpose
x86 machines in racks a and D and their
job is to feed and manage the TPU core
when you request one cloud CPU you don't
get just the TPU device itself you also
get the dedicated server for that TPU
device so one cloud TPU is actually two
pieces of hardware often in two separate
racks okay so that's what the physical
hardware is how does this look like from
like a cloud platform perspective I'm
going to talk about TPU is on compute
engine but this applies for the other
higher level products which I'll talk
about later in the talk but if you have
a bunch of compute engine VMs running in
your private network if you're like me
you'll often store your data in Google
Cloud storage in a storage bucket
this means it's available to multiple GC
VMs it's really cheap really scalable
and when you want to allocate a clout
TPU what happens is you get the
dedicated cloud TPU host and TPU device
and in order to access them we open up
this network peering channel or this
bridge and once that's open you can
actually connect to it from your GCE VMs
/ tensor flows open source G RPC
protocol now in this picture I'm showing
one compute engine VM talking to one
cloud TPU but this is designed for
maximum control and flexibility so you
can have multiple VMs talking to one
cloud TPU you can have one VM
controlling multiple cloud GPUs or any
combination you want cool so how do you
make that happen well it's just a couple
of G cloud commands away g-cloud compute
instances create to create your GC VM
g-cloud compute GPUs create to create
your TPU SSH in your VM install
tensorflow and you're off to the races
well not quite so fast this is a sort of
complicated command so let's break it
down a little bit when you create a
cloud TPU you need to specify the
version of tensorflow installed and the
reason for that is because tensorflow is
not designed to work across different
versions if you're running a distributed
tensorflow cluster where one node is
running tensorflow 1.8 and one node is
running tensorflow 1.9 you're going to
have a really bad day the errors are
absolutely unintelligible so when you
create a cloud teeth you need to
if I what version of tensorflow do you
want to use additionally you have to
specify what network address range you
want to give over to the TPU so the TPU
can be paired on to your network and so
you can see the list of routes pick a
route that is unoccupied and go for that
now this is sort of involved and
requires too much thinking and so
because I create a lot of cloudy views
as part of using them I created a tool
called CTP you now see TPU is short for
the cloud TPU provisioning utility and
if you just run CTP you up it will
basically set everything up for you
launch of GC VM with penciler flow
pre-installed create your cloud TPU make
sure it's paired up appropriately and it
will even SSH you into your GC VM get
you all ready to go
one thing to note CTP you up is designed
to be item potent so if you have like a
GC VM already running and your amp table
cloud TPU got preempted you want to get
things back into a working state just
rerun see TPU up it'll SSH you back in
cool so now that we have the cloud
resources let's actually run something
on our cloud TPU right the whole point
of this I would be remiss if I did not
emphasize the availability of our
reference models for cloud GPUs they
span a wide variety of vertical domains
they're tested they work really well
some of them are even commented it's
really nice they're available on open
source on github and on our cloud TPU
VMs if you one if you provision to VM
with CTP you they're available on the
filesystem at user share TPU but this is
the tensorflow
cloud cheap you deep dive so we're going
to ignore these big fancy scripts and
we're going to go down to the basis
barest level and so we're going to
ignore those for the for the rest of
this talk tensorflow underneath its hood
is a distributed graph execution engine
you build up a computational graph often
with Python you pass it to the core
tensorflow distributed runtime and you
then execute that crap so here we have a
graph for a two layer neural network and
you can see the graph executing and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
build a simple graph and execute it on a
GPU so this is the technical deep dive
so we're going to see a lot of code
today here is a very simple
implementation of a linear agressor you
tensorflow so we first describe our
stateful nodes in our graph our
variables W and B these are the values
we want to learn we then take as input x
and y these are our training data and
our training labels we compute our
predicted values YP with a matrix
multiplied because x and y are batches
of training values we compute the loss
by doing the squared error and we want
to minimize the loss so we want to take
advantage of tensor flows automatic
differentiation and gradient update
capabilities with our optimizer we're
using Adam which is a variation on a
momentum optimizer highly recommended so
this is a linear regressor in low-level
tensorflow how do you make it work on a
TPU well as it turns out you don't
change anything about your model you
keep that all the same go what you need
to do is you need to tell tensorflow
hey this part make this go on the TPU
and so to do that you pass your model
function the part that describes your
model that you want to run on the TPU
you pass that to this TF contribute and
what this will do is this will tell
tensorflow put this part of the
computational graph that I'm building
onto the TPU once you've done that
you've now built a tensor flow graph
that is set up to run on a TPU so now
let's actually run it to run at a
computational graph in tensor flow
you've got to create a tensor flow
session but you can't pass the TPU name
to the tensor flow session constructor
doesn't know how to this open standard
open source tensor flow it doesn't know
anything about cloud TP use so how do
you make this work but we have this
thing in terms our flow called cluster
resolvers and so we have a TPU cluster
resolver where you pass that the name of
your cloud TP you a well on your behalf
contact the cloud TPU API figure out all
the metadata about your cloud TPU and
take care of all the underlying details
for you so to create a tensor flow
session on a cloud TPU you just create
the cluster resolver and you pass that
to your session constructor one thing to
note if you are using C TPU or you're
running on kubernetes engine or other
environments the TPU cluster resolver is
clever enough to inspect your
environment to figure out what your TPU
name probably is and so you can pass
none and it will try and figure out what
what
actually should be there so this is
really convenient if you're sharing
scripts across multiple people are
sharing multiple cloud TP use cool so
now that we have the session it's really
straightforward to actually run our
program on the cloud TPU so here we're
doing random variables because there's a
toy example we initialize the TPU system
and then we're sort of off to the races
now one thing to note this TPU
initialized system is relatively heavy
weight so it's going to clear the entire
TPU system state interrupts any running
TP programs that are running on the TPU
devices rebuilds the mesh network and
gets everything ready and clean for you
to use after that here we're gonna run a
hundred steps of our training loop print
out the losses and and shutdown the
system so if you were to paste all this
into Fuu dot pi and type Python Fuu dot
pi enter you'll see your cursor blinked
for like ten or fifteen seconds and then
hundred lines have lost so we printed
out so there's ten or fifteen seconds
that's initializing the TPU system
working on making that goal but faster
but then after that the computation runs
really quickly okay so we just talked
about how we programmed it from a
low-level standpoint but what actually
happened inside the cloud TPU cloud TP
use the TPU chips they're not x86 chips
you can't run a standard program that
you get out of GCC or clang and so in
order to run a program on a cloud TPU
you need to have a compiler and we use
the excel a compiler so what is excel a
excel a stands for accelerated linear
algebra and it's this custom
domain-specific compiler that takes in
high-level pure functional programs in a
language called a cello and it outputs
optimized binary programs for either
CPUs GPUs or TP use now Excel a it has a
few restrictions it's a linear
high-level linear algebra based language
you've got matrix multiplies
convolutions broadcast reduce some ops
etc but you don't have like very branchy
things like JPEG decode or other sorts
of low-level operations additionally you
have to we require static shapes but in
exchange for these restrictions we give
you a few superpowers the first one is
operation fusion now operation fusion I
think is best illustrated in an example
if you're trying to write a program to
sum three very large matrices but your
matrix library only has support for
summing two matrices together well you
can work around that by doing a plus B
and write that to a temporary value and
then do temporary plus C and get your
eventual value and you can do that but
it's a performance cost
you've got to read and write this
temporary value and it ends up being the
very significant performance cost xla
because it sees your whole program and
it optimizes everything it can actually
give you the optimal program without
having you specify it so that's one EXO
a superpower and what this gives you is
this means you can write your own
composite operations you aren't stuck
into restricted kernels that are only
work well for for certain hardware
devices you can invent your own
primitives that then get compiled to
high-performance programs that run on
the TPU additionally because xla is a
whole program optimizer and it's in this
pure functional language this means we
can actually not just optimize the
instructions that get executed on your
processor but this means we can optimize
the memory layouts as well so I think
this most often comes up if you're doing
convolutional networks on GPUs today the
recommendation was to do what's called
channels first for most GPUs you got
much better performance if you did NCH
wr8 batch channels height width but
actually on the latest Voltas with their
tensor cores you get far better
performance if you go back to the
standard tensor flow image format which
is channels last and hwc with xla you
never have to worry about what is your
memory shape formats or whatever it will
pick the optimal format for your
hardware based on what program you're
trying to do compile your program just
for you the final thing that XLE does is
it does software pipelining really
really well and we'll see why that's
important a little bit later so fine
excellet is great cool what does it
matter to me I'm a tensorflow programmer
right I don't want to write xla programs
well that's what we have what's called
the tensor flow to excel a bridge and
what this will do is this will take a
tensor flow graph and this will convert
some of your part of your graph to be an
excellent program so how this works is
we've got these tf2 xl8 kernels so
you've marked out in the rewrite for TP
you
function you've marked out a subset of
your tensor flow graph to run on the TPU
and so we'll do is we'll go through up
by op and translate them into portions
of the excel a program here the excel a
graph on the right hand side for ad it's
a straightforward one-to-one mapping but
for softmax there is no softmax what's
called a cello op and so instead the
kernel builds up the softmax operation
from the set of primitives what this
means is that if you want to write your
own operation that's different than
softmax you can build it up from your
own primitives and it will run just as
fast as softmax modulo the performance
characteristics of your computation
right there's nothing special once we've
finished translating the whole program
into the excel a graph the tensorflow
runtime will execute the excel a
compiler on the excel a program that it
built up for you replace that subset of
your graph with this custom excel a
program and then it will run the graph
just like you'd expect okay
so that tells us like what bits of
software involved but like let's take
one level deeper what actually happened
on the TPU chips in order to understand
that we need to understand what are the
TPU chips we need to see what's going on
with them so one TPU chip this is a v2
chip the v3 chip has double the amount
of HB m and is a little bit faster in
the core but in a v2 chip you've got two
cores each core is identical so let's
double click on one of the cores and see
what's going on you've got three key
components you've got the scalar unit
you've got the vector unit in the matrix
unit so the scalar unit that's typically
used for loop indexing making sure if
you're doing a loop n times you do it n
times
computing addresses in memory things
like that the vector unit is very
sophisticated it has support for float32
this is I Triple E float in 32 this
funky format be float 16 which we'll
hear about in a minute through software
it can support a lot of other formats
like in 64 complex 64 etc we've got a in
32 real part and in 32 imaginary etc and
it lets you do all sorts of things
compute transcendentals things like that
but the real heart of the cloud TPU
is the matrix unit so this is a special
hardware circuit design called a
systolic array and so the matrix unit is
a 128 by 128 matrix multiplies systolic
array and it is optimized for machine
learning it takes in as input B float16
or float32 values computes the
multiplication in this format B float16
sums up the values in float32
and the output is then in float32 so for
those of you who need a bit of a
refresher course on I Triple E floating
point format I know I certainly did
here's my brief handy-dandy guide so I
Triple E to find what's called single
precision floating point format and this
uses 32 bits and is often called FP 32
you've got one sign bit you've got 8
bits of exponent and then the rest of
the 32 bits so you got 23 bits left
that's the mantissa or the significant
that's sort of like how precise of a
number you're able to specify now I
Triple E also defined a 16-bit half
precision floating point format and this
is sort of the very natural extension
from FP 32 you take a little few bits
away from the exponent and take a few
bits away from the mantissa bada-bing
bada-boom
you got 16-bit floating-point format one
thing to note however is that the range
ends up being quite drastically reduced
and when you train neural networks
you'll find that if you want to use
float 16 and there are a lot of good
reasons why you want to use a 16-bit
floating-point floating-point format you
have to do a bunch of clever tricks in
order to make sure that keeps training
if you most times when you train a
neural network and FP 16 without into
any modifications your losses will
explode to infinity or you'll get not a
number Nan's
or your your your model just won't train
you'll have vanishing gradients that go
down to zero and this is because neural
networks really need a large range in
order to often train effectively we
recognize this at Google because we
train a lot of neural networks and so we
did a bunch of studies across a broad
range of neural networks and we realized
that if you have a different
floating-point format this can often be
a drop-in replacement so we invented on
the Google brain team the B float16
format this is short for brain
floating-point format
in 16bits this preserves the exact same
range of FP 32 but does it in 16 bits
and as it turns out this is often a
drop-in replacement for FB 32 but
because it's only in 16 bits it takes
half the space that means your memory
feels twice as large this means that
your memory Bend with this twice as fast
so it's a really cool performance
optimisation that we've done in TP use
cool so now that we know about
floating-point formats let's talk a
little more about them matrix multiply
unit this is a 128 by 128 matrix
multiply units does that mean that my
model has to be composed entirely of 128
by 128 matrix multiplies well the answer
is no so here's a study on ResNet 15 and
I took a single cloud TPU device that
you can run today and I basically sweep
a number of different batch sizes and
this is per core batch size so remember
a TPU device has eight cores this is our
per core batch size as you go from 1 to
8 you'll see performance is increasing
very significantly we reach our peak
performance at batch size 128 so what's
going on here the excel a compiler is
able to realize that if your baptizes
128 that fits really nicely with the 128
by 128 matrix multiply unit but to
really understand what's going on I
think it's easiest if you if we plot it
on a log scale right we're doubling the
per core batch size on the Y ax on the x
axis so let's turn the y-axis also into
a logarithmic scale and here it's a
little easier to see we've got two
distinct trends two piecewise
performance where we increase
performance practically linearly from
batch size one to batch size eight but
after that performance improves only a
little bit what this means is that Excel
a is able to do a really good job
software pipelining all the
optimizations after you get to batch
size 8 on a cloud TP you now this is
just on res net 50 there have been a
variety of other models that work really
really well at even smaller batch sizes
depending upon whatever things are so
one question we often get is do I need
to have my model be baptized 120 or do
you need to have my model be like 128
everywhere the answer is of course no
Excel a takes care of getting you the
optimal code generation across a ride of
different model architectures and that's
okay so now we know a little bit about
the chip now we can really delve down
and figure out what actually happened in
our linear aggressive program on a TPU
so the first step is we load the weights
into our matrix multiply unit after that
we stream through our training data into
the matrix multiply unit compute the
matrix multiply and stream the output
out now I mentioned about operation
fusion Excel a is actually able to in
parallel stream the values into the
vector unit compute the loss or the
activations or whatever other operations
your model requests and stream those
values out in parallel as a result you
get really high performance and you're
really able to take advantage of all the
capabilities on the chip so we've been
delving really deep into one single
program but as it turns out all we've
been doing is running on a single core
of our cloud TPU device GPUs are
designed to be networked together and
they're designed to be parallel devices
so multi-core execution is very
important as it turns out because we
have this custom network and because we
designed these things from the ground up
for parallel compute it's actually
really easy to make these go not just on
a single core but across cores up to a
whole pod all you need to do is you need
to take your optimizer and wrap it in
this TPU cross shard optimizer what this
means is this coordinates the
optimization routines that are being run
on your model across all the different
compute cores in a teepee device all the
way up to a whole TPU pod after that you
just say batch parallel instead of
rewrite so this is a higher level API
specify the number of shards and done
you're off to the races that is all you
need to do so we've been walking through
how to write a teep u program we've been
using low-level tensorflow this is
because we wanted to see what's going on
underneath the hood but really no one
writes low-level tensorflow on GPUs it
is too verbose that low-level api's were
optimizing and changing relatively
frequently it means you're locked into a
TPU program there's a lot of features
and performance optimizations that are
also very hard to write in low-level
tensorflow so
we program TP use the first thing I want
to tell you about is TPU estimator so
tensorflow is designed to go across a
wide variety of platforms that go from
research to production and many of our
production users have realized that many
of their problems can be decomposed into
two key aspects the first aspect is
describing your machine learning model
is this random forest a convolutional
neural network a deep neural network and
these models are often generic across
the input data so you write a second
input function that describes what data
you want to load in and by decomposing
this into these two distinct parts you
then pass these functions to the core
estimator logic and the estimator takes
care of all the nitty-gritty things like
handling failures checkpointing
exporting for inference a whole bunch of
other really nice things and so the
tensor flow estimator API is used by a
vast majority of production teams at
Google and so we wanted to make it
really easy to take your model and go
from estimators to TPU estimators
whether you're ending on CPUs and GPUs
before or TP use so here's a code sample
of actually a full working estimator
based model so I've sort of masked out
the bottom on the top this is identical
code if you're running with standard
estimators or TPU estimators at the top
of the model function we describe our
deep neural network we have our
optimizer on the right-hand side we've
got our input function so we're loading
data from a path on disk we're parsing
out our TF record values and returning a
data set that has that the training data
we want to train on the only changes are
in the bottom half and aside from a few
mechanical changes changing standard
estimator to TPU estimator and standard
estimated respect to tip you SMA respect
there's only two small changes excuse me
the first one is as we saw before you'll
want to run across multiple cores on a
TPU device your TPU device is way faster
when they all work together so you've
got to use that cross shard optimizer
the only other thing is to pass the TPU
cluster is Oliver that we saw before so
that estimator knows how to
your TPU on the network that's it it's
really easy to go from an estimator that
runs on CPUs or GPUs to an estimator to
keep us tomatoe that will run on GPUs
all the way up to a whole TPU pot but I
won't actually call out one thing we own
the tensor flow team we want to go
wherever you want to go for your machine
learning workloads this means CPUs this
means GPUs and this means TP use and so
we've worked very hard so that if you
just pass use TP u is equal to false to
a TPU estimator model you will get
identical behavior to standard
estimators that run on all your other
platforms so once you migrate to TP
estimator and it's very easy to run on
any platform you want CPUs GPUs or TP
use let's dig one level deeper and give
you a bit of intuition about this
abstraction the model function is what
runs on the TPU this gets compiled by
Excel a and goes really really fast the
input function runs on the x86 CPU hosts
that are attached and now that you know
sort of a little bit of intuition about
what's going on
you can start doing funny optimizations
say for example you have some input
pre-processing that logically belongs in
the input function but it's super
computationally expensive and the CPUs
just can't keep up well you can put that
at the top of your model function and to
have that compiled and run on the TPU
and as long as you know it compiles for
the TPU you can get all the performance
advantages of running on the accelerator
device by contrast if you have something
that can't compile for the TPU go ahead
and hoist that into your input function
with one key restriction if you need to
take the gradient of it that ball has to
happen in the model function it does
have to go under the TPU because that's
the way we do the cross shard
coordination is on the TPU device itself
we totally keep the CPUs out of the path
because that's how we get the amazing
performance that we see on TV use GPU
estimator is designed and is in design
for production reliability scalability
and performance it automatically handles
failures so it does automatically saving
checkpoints and restoring from the
checkpoints there's a very stable API
it doesn't change very much even though
it still is in contribute you just
define your model and your input
function and construct your estimator
you're off to the races but we've heard
from a lot of folks that although they
really like TPU estimator we've heard
some other folks that they don't quite
like it they want a little more
flexibility they want a little bit more
control and so I'm really excited to
announce to you today that Karis on
cloud GPUs will be available in
tensorflow 110 our release candidates
for TF 110 just got first release
candidates drop just yesterday but we're
really excited about what this brings to
our cloud GPU users so let's talk about
how this Karis integration actually
works here is a convolutional network
running on a standard Kerris model that
runs on CPUs or GPUs let's convert it to
run on GPUs okay done I don't change
anything you write your model exactly as
you did before the only thing you have
to do is you pass your existing standard
chaos model to Karis support TPU model
and you pass in a couple extra things
like your distribution strategy and the
cloud TPU you want to run on this will
return to you a TPU a5 Karis model after
that that's it use it just like a
standard chaos model passing in numpy
data passing a data set do whatever you
want with it call fit call fit generator
call evaluate use it just like a
standard chaos model we're really
excited about the flexibility that this
sort of an API and caris brings Karis is
a really great API and framework for
machine learning a lot of people really
like it now it's even easier than ever
before to go to TPO hardware so now that
we have multiple API is well how do you
choose which one if you already have a
model that's using estimators definitely
migrate just two TPU estimator this will
give you production grade performance
it's reliable it's very robust works
very well if you have a lot of chaos
models
definitely try out our new experimental
chaos integration this is a lot more
flexible and people really like it who
have tried it so far
but if you haven't started I want to
give you a bit of an intuition if you're
starting something from scratch I wanna
give you bit of intuition as to which
API you should choose one thing to note
though the same team is developing both
TPU estimator and Karis and so although
there are current advantages one versus
the other
expect feature convergence over time for
now though TPU estimator scales two
whole pods with zero code changes it's
super fast has all the performance
optimizations in it caris by contrast is
a bit more flexible and easy to use
error messages are often a little bit
easier to understand
it supports non-static shapes through a
bunch of dynamic recompilation
underneath the hood for you so we're
really excited about both these two
api's if you want more flexibility go
with Karis if you're in production you
want peak performance go with TPU
estimator now I've gone through the
mechanics of how do you actually program
these cloud TPU devices but as we've
migrated a huge number of customers from
other hardware platforms to TP use we've
done this both internally at Google and
externally on as part of Google Cloud
we've gleaned a number of best practices
and tips so I'd like to walk you through
a few of them today far and away the
best advice we can give you is if
possible start with a reference model
these are well tuned they're reasonably
clean they are tested to converge
reliably to our resident 50
implementation if you train it on
imagenet you're gonna get 76.2% top 1
accuracy every single time these are
high quality both in the machine
learning and in the performance but if
you can't and you have an existing code
base that you've invested in for your
machine learning model we have a
workflow that often works pretty well
step one is on your existing hardware
port two estimators this often results
in a bunch of code getting deleted that
you sort of manually we're doing like
checkpoints and things like that and
then at this step once you've completed
your port to estimator be sure to verify
convergence
this is often a mistake that people skip
once you're sure that your model is
working exactly as you expect then do
the mechanical change from estimator to
TPU estimator start with use TP
false and make sure that the mechanical
changes work just fine and after that
turn on GPUs and you're off to the races
and finally be sure to optimize
performance you won't see the full
benefit of cloud GPUs if you ensure
they're not being bottlenecked by your
CPU input pipeline now this is a very
common workflow migrating existing
models to TPU hardware but we've
actually seen a lot of people just start
on cloud CPUs natively there are a
number of really compelling advantages
for that in addition to being cheaper
most importantly they're fast and so you
can iterate much more quickly than you
can on any other hardware platform that
we that we see so if you want to bring
up a brand new model from scratch you're
not starting from one of our existing
models be sure to iterate very regularly
as you it's much easier to debug a few
lines of code Delta than it is a
thousand line model function with a very
sophisticated network if you're trying
to figure out you know your shape
inference you need static shapes and
shape inference isn't working right much
easier to figure that out if you just
changed a couple lines and if you have
to hunt through a thousand line model
function so iterate regularly as a bonus
tip make sure to optimize your input
pipeline performance early this just is
gas on the iteration speed and just
helps you go a whole lot faster once
you've got a basic thing working
usually on a single cloud TP advice take
advantage of what is the magic of TP use
which is you can scale scale these out
to whole fleets to run hyper parameter
searches in parallel or scale up to
train your models super super fast get
results turnaround
optimize your model and and develop your
system so there are some of the
high-level best practices let's dig down
again to the nitty gritty when you're
developing models on cloud TP use some
of us aren't perfect coders we end up
putting bugs in our systems and so I'll
walk you through some common errors that
people sometimes stumble upon so that
you have an intuition for what's going
on and how to solve these common issues
that come up so the first one is
unimplemented error this file scheme
local is not implemented it tells you
the file that it's trying to do and
you'll like grep through your code and
you're like no where do
reference last time what the heck's
going on this is very common because
estimators and therefore TPU estimator
handles software failures
it handles hardware failures it handles
other problems in your system and so as
a result it requires a checkpoint
directory so it can save and restore
training progress and if you don't
provide it a checkpoint directory it
will hopefully create one for you on
slash temp now when you try and run this
on a cloud TPU the cloud TPU is a
totally different device it cannot read
or write to slash temp on your GCE VM
this to totally break all the security
abstractions like it just doesn't work
and so what's happening here is that
it's trying to do that just that so the
solution is to whenever you're running a
TPU estimator model on a cloud TPU be
sure to specify the model directory
that's where your checkpoints get saved
to and they get restored from you need
to set the checkpoint directory to be
someplace on a shared file system that
both the cloud TPU and your Python
process can read and write to this is
often GCS Google Cloud Storage another
common error message is the following it
does not found error no registered where
up kernel for Excel a TPU JIT so what's
going on here well remember that tensor
flow graph gets converted into an Excel
a graph which then gets compiled and
runs on the TPU device and what's
happening is we don't have a tf2
excellet kernel for the wear off okay
and so what you need to do is see if you
can restructure your program your tensor
flow graph to not use these ops that we
don't have a translation for index la
alternatively you could implement that
you have to Excel a kernel because all
these are fully open sourced you can
implement your own or file a bug and
we'll see if we can prioritize getting
those op kernels implemented ok another
common error message that people might
see is the following not found Aaron
Noah district a stop kernel flex la TPU
J aha well we've seen this one before
right well as it turns out it's a little
subtle the final parenthetical is the
key difference the op kernel was found
so there is a tf2 excel a top kernel but
the attributes didn't match so let's dig
into what are the attributes you've got
our destination type
of DT in 16-hour source type DT float
and a device now the device is fine the
issue is actually DT in 16 GPUs don't
support in 16 they only support float 32
or DC float in 32 etcetera so the
solution here is to instead of trying to
cast to in 16 leave it as float or cast
to in 32 if you want to see what ops a
priori before you get these error
messages if you want to see what ops are
likely compatible with GPUs or not we
have this really cool TPU compatibility
checker and the tool the tools page
documents really clearly how you can use
it now one thing to note we're
constantly adding new kernel
implementations and supporting new data
types etc and so the source of truth is
often the compiler and the tensorflow
version you're actually using so beware
that there is some Delta between that
the tool says in reality the final error
message that people often stumble over
is the following not found error op type
not registered - now remember cloud
Tipu's are this distributed computation
device your Python runs on your GCE VM
but the cloud CPU has no python
available to it on the CPU it's just a
C++ binary as it turns out and so you
can't use PI funks on your cloud CPU
however with a little bit of cleverness
you can use PI function your input
function like we are here our input
pipeline task 0 you can do that with a
technique I'm going to show you in the
next section which brings me to feeding
a TPU program so I want to take a step
back before we delve into this and
actually remark upon a trend that is
happening across GPUs in fact if you
look at in videos Volta GPUs they're
phenomenal accelerators they're really
fast and in videos on a great job
working on them and if you try to run a
fast model on NVIDIA voltage GPUs like
ResNet 50 on a DG x1 you'll find that
the local SSD can't keep up we've seen
this in tensor flow as we benchmark on a
wide variety of hardware platforms that
unless you have a high-performance
storage system your accelerator is
actually going to sit idle waiting for
data to be fed in and in this case just
the raw throughput of the SSD can't keep
up if you have the data in memory on
your Ram disk you're fine but if it's on
the SSD and you've got a cold Ram disk
or cold buffer cache you're not and if
you try and optimize around this it can
often be quite pricey so one company
found that the storage costs alone on a
non GCP platform was more expensive than
the entire cloud TPU solution including
storage including the cloud TP use
themselves in this case it was
preemptable including the GC VMs to
drive it so the entire GC solution was
cheaper than just storage on a Senate
platform the GPUs could be completely
free the compute could be in completely
free the VMS the compute everything
could be completely free
just the storage alone was more
expensive and so to tell you about how
you can feed fast accelerators TP use
but also GPUs on Google cloud platform
this is available all these are
available in standard tensorflow
I want to walk you through three ways
that you can do this so the first and
most common way is Google Cloud storage
this is a distributed file system that
is optimized for both extreme scale and
shockingly low cost the next one that
people often do is use compute engine
this allows you to stream data from
either local SSDs or in-memory data
structures this is where you can use PI
funks to pre-process your data you can
stream the data from GC VMs into a cloud
TPU and finally I'm really excited to
announce a brand new integration coming
intends to flow 1.10 over the next few
weeks that is cloud BigTable BigTable
for those of you who are not familiar is
a wide row structured storage system
scales out horizontally and has amazing
performance both for low latency as well
as high throughput which is relatively
unique for a system of this caliber so
to walk you through what these all are
like and how to use them let's dig right
in cloud storage is definitely the
default choice
a familiar abstraction files on a
distributed file system people are easy
it's very easy to work with has very
nice UI is integration to the wide
variety of different tools I have some
tips and tricks for you to make sure you
can get the best performance out of
Google Cloud storage
the first one is make sure you select
regional storage so not multi-regional
not near line not cold line we're also
going to get a nasty bill at the end of
the month because those are end up being
far more expensive for use with high
performance compute devices like cloud
TV use
additionally make sure that your data is
in the exact same region as your
accelerators US central One or Europe
West 4 or in Taiwan
additionally GCS is optimized for high
throughput but not low latency and so in
order to work around in order to achieve
high performance you need to batch your
data into large often TF record files we
found that 100 megabytes to 200
megabytes works very well to allow it's
a sort of a sweet spot between
parallelism and throughput of the files
to handle all this complicated data
loading and parallelism and software
pipelining TF data makes it very easy so
let's walk through an example here we're
loading a set of TF record files in this
case from a GCSE path we're reading 32
files in parallel and after that we've
constructed a data set that we can then
process or do whatever we want this
works of course for cloud GPUs but
GPUs on GCE etc that's it just two lines
of code it's pretty easy the next one I
want to talk about is compute engine VMs
we have a few different ways that you
can feed data into cloud TP use at high
performance the first one is the
streaming files data set this is a
software pipeline data in feed that you
can read from local disk often local SSD
because that's faster than persistent
disk SSD but you can feed from both and
with streaming files you can actually
use arbitrary Python to pre-process the
data using PI funks or otherwise to
stream it in into the cloud CPU now
often we found if you do try and use PI
funks now
performance bottleneck but for certain
models this absolutely makes a lot of
sense it's also great as an
experimentation or getting started tool
additionally we have a second method
which is this RPC op you can actually
load data from any arbitrary G RPC
server as long as you implement a small
G RPC interface this works really well
when data is being generated on the fly
especially if that is stored in memory
for example in reinforcement learning
typestyle workloads so to give you an
illustration of what's going on you have
a compute engine VM and you're passing
the streaming files data set from the VM
streaming the data from the VM into the
cloud GPU now tensorflow is designed as
a distributed execution engine so you
can actually stream data from multiple
GC VMs into one cloud EQ or of course
you can use the RPC app for one or more
GC VMs to take a look at some code to
see how you'd actually do this here's an
example of the streaming files data set
reading from a local path on disk in
this case we're doing TF records but if
you wanted to do more complicated
pre-processing you can pass in a few
extra arguments and you're off to the
races one thing to note you do have to
configure your TPU cluster is Oliver a
little bit differently in order to
ensure that the cloud CPU knows where to
find your GC VM to pull the data from
and finally I'd like to talk a few
minutes about cloud BigTable in some
benchmarks cloud BigTable has been shown
to be over 10 times faster than Google
Cloud storage so it's this amazing
performance system and because it's a
database high scale database you can
have a flexible schema and you can query
your data in a variety of different
patterns so it's really valuable for
experimentation or other sorts of
workloads additionally if you're
generating your data on the fly from say
multiple worker BMS as you're doing like
self play and a reinforcement learning
algorithm you can stream the data into
big table and you don't have to create
your own batch record files or anything
like that
BigTable handles all of that for you
automatically I have a sample script
available on github for how to load as
TF records into BigTable but it's
designed to be easily flexible and
rewritten to stream data of whatever
format you want in
big table getting data out of the big
table is also really easy with TF data
you create a big table client you open
the table and then you can scan rows
either by range or by prefix specifying
whatever column families and columns you
want out this gives you a data set that
you can use just like normal
so with TF data it's very flexible and
very easy to switch between all these
different data sources while maintaining
your pre-processing operations etc they
are lower down in your input function
now that we have choices well how do you
choose this walks through sort of the
pricing of these different storage
solutions so Google Cloud Storage is two
cents per gigabyte per month and is the
cheapest the other storage systems have
different prices as listed Google Cloud
Storage you don't pay unless you're
pulling data out of it so the hourly
overheads are zero which is really nice
on the second half of the slide of this
table I walk through sort of the pricing
example if you have a one terabyte
training data set and you train on it
for ten hours
here's your cost for just the storage
and for everything all in whether using
a standard cloud GPU or a preemptable
cloud GPU so that's an overview of our
three main areas what's going on
underneath the hood of a cloud to you
how to program a cloud GPU using our new
api's and finally how to feed data but I
want to take this all back to really the
whole purpose which is you we've talked
about how to use cloud GPUs on compute
engine but you can also use it on cloud
ml engine or kubernetes engine cloud ml
engine makes it very very easy to switch
between CPUs GPUs or TP use just change
one flag for your model and your and and
and resubmit your job kubernetes has
this new integration where you can
request a cloud TP you to be provisioned
a deep provision for you
as part of your pods when your pause get
launched and deleted on the on the
kubernetes cluster so these higher-level
api's are really nice they handle a lot
of the convenience you have to worry
about network ranges etc so really
excited to have all three of these
different engines available to you
for your workloads for whatever your
style of work is but I want to take a
step back and realize well what are GPUs
really and I want to sort of take a
different interpretation of things this
is a plot that shows the performance of
a model as it scales across a single
cloud TPU device up to a whole
second-generation cloud TPU pod of 64
devices and the dotted line is perfect
scaling and a blue line is the observed
performance now this is a cool chart
that shows like yes with who our custom
mesh network is superfast but what this
means for you is that you write your
model on a single cloud TPU device and
with zero code changes you scale it up
to a whole cloud TPU pod and you get
your answers linearly times faster in
many cases this means that TP use are
like a time machine instead of having to
wait days or weeks you can iterate in
hours or even faster
and this just super charges both ml
research as well as ml product
development we're bringing all this
technology to you as we optimize from
our storage systems our compute our
network and our TPU devices we're
bringing all this great technology to
you the sky's the limit
develop your applications ethically
conduct your research responsibly but
I'm super excited to see what you all
are build thank you very much for your
time today
[Applause]
few extra sessions three times the time
third a few extra sessions available
that you cannot see there we go
that are also relevant to tea pews if
you're interested and I'm happy to take
questions over off to the side because I
am way out of time thank you
[Music]